لاني لابرز ما ورد في منصات التواصل في
فقره ترند اليوم اثار استفتاء اجراه مالك
شركه تويتر الجديد لهم ماسك حول عوده
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
للمنصه اثار جدلا واسعا حيث اعتبره بعض
رواد منصات التواصل انتصارا لحريه التعبير
فيما اعتبره اخرون محاوله من مصر لاعاده
الزخم الى المنصه عبر اعاده المحظورين
وكان ماسك قد اعلن عوده بعض الحسابات
المحظوره الى منصه تويتر واوضح ماسك في
تغريده عبر حسابه انه اعاده حسابا ممثل
الكوميديه الامريكيه كاسي جيري
والاكاديميه المثير للجدل جوردان بيترسون
وحساب موقع بافيلم بيل للاخبار الساخره
والذين حضارتهم المنصه في وقت سابق لكنه
ماسك اشار الى ان قرار اعادته حساب الرئيس
الامريكي الساب رونالدو لن يتم اتخاذه بعد
ونشر مسك الاستفتاء صباح اليوم وحظيه
باهتمام واسعا من جانب المتابعين حيث شارك
فيه اكثر من ثمانيه ملايين شخص حتى الان
ومن المنتظر ان تنتهي مده الاستفتاء خلال
اربعين 24 ساعه
نقرا بعضا من التفاعلات على هذا الاستفتاء
قال مايكل ترايسي همم ما يزال من الجنون
انه تم حظره في المقام الاول يدعو
السياسيون الى الحرب العالميه الثالثه كل
يوم على تويتر ولا يحدث شيء وقال اجرهم
الي يجب ان يكون هذا تلقائيا لانه يرشح
نفسه الان لمنصب الرئيس واذا كنت تؤمن حقا
بما تقوله فلا يمكن اسكات احد المرشحين
بينما يستطيعون الاخرون تحدث في الساحه
العامه
في المقابل قال جون كراير ساصوت بلا له
ماسك لقد انتهت ترامب مرارا شروط خدمه
تويتر وارتكب جرائم تستوجب عزله بالاضافه
الى جريمه فعليه عبر المنصه اتذكر عندما
حاول تخويف شاهدا فيدراليا بتقليده عوده
الى المنصه تشير الى موافقتك على هذا